[موسيقى]
لذا ، خامسًا ، كان الكونسورتيوم يعمل فعليًا
عن كثب مع هؤلاء الشركاء في
البحرين وتحديداً البنك المركزي
بالإضافة إلى مجلس التنمية الاقتصادية
للمساعدة في وضع
إستراتيجية شاملة يجب
على منطقة الشرق الأوسط فعلاً القيام بها  التكيف مع
تكتيكات العالم المتغيرة للغاية ، يعد التمويل أحد
تلك المجالات التي تعتبر نوعًا من الأسود خلفنا
رأينا صعود واستخدام
التكنولوجيا والتطبيقات المتعددة
من عقد الإيجار سواء كانت
للاستخدام الترفيهي للسفر أو التجارة الإلكترونية
ولكن التمويل  لم تتشكل حقًا
[موسيقى]
أي شخص يأتي إلى إيطاليا سيكون قادرًا على
عرض حله ليكون قادرًا على
فوكين يمكنه أن يشهد على تلك الحلول في
هذا الصدد ، لقد قمنا بتربية
أشخاص مثل هذا لن ينجح سنقول
رولا Microsoft  لقد جلبت جميع Cisco
بعض المستشفيات
لتكون جزءًا من حبيبتي
[موسيقى]